[Music]
like guys like you
and mess it up every time
maybe you just need a partner
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you it's crazy could be ghosts
stole your tech deal Jessica
this video
ant-man the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Applause]
I just have one question when cap needed
help if I'd asked you would you have
come I guess we'll never know but if you
had you'd have never been caught
[Music]
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run
we're still running let's go
[Music]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
[Music]
where were ant-man and the wasps
did you see the monsoon where was Tim
chair good question
no I mean really I have no idea I mean I
don't remember being asked to be in
their movie just saying maybe they were
on their way but they went subatomic
maybe they were they're pretty tiny and
there were definitely some ants of a
condoisseur Phoebe there are in the same
places Hawkeye Gamora saw spider-man I
was really looking forward to meeting
the wasp yeah no not that
we're
you
you